[Music]
hey wisecrack
jared here have you ever had a really
bad day
gone home and eaten an entire pizza and
two tubs of ice cream
has the pressure of needing to pay bills
left you in the fetal position
curled up with your dog replaying
untitled goose game for the ninth time
we've all experienced it at some point
being anxious
exhausted stressed according to the
american psychological association
77 of people living in the us regularly
experience
physical symptoms of stress and if
you've experienced the turmoil of being
unable to sleep at night because of the
thoughts racing through your head
there's a good chance someone's
recommended you fix it by using an
approach called mindfulness
at its most basic level mindfulness is
just concentration training
achieving a calm mental state by
focusing on the present moment
instead of fixating on the past or
worrying about the future
the practice touted by everyone from
oprah winfrey to paul mccartney
has turned into a four billion dollar
industry it's the subject of numerous
self-help books and online courses and
has even made its way into beauty
products
wellness cruises and spawned countless
apps
but is this cure-all for stress too good
to be true
while practicing mindfulness definitely
has benefits critics think it also might
be turning us into
self-absorbed zombies focusing on our
breathing might make us feel better
but some think the way we're going about
it might be making the world at large
a little worse and i'm not just talking
about this
the zen of steam how to form a golden
crust around your spirit
so take a deep breath focus on the sound
of my voice and welcome this wisecrack
edition
on mindfulness is it deep or dumb
mindfulness isn't new in fact it's very
old the modern mindfulness movement
credits an essential spiritual practice
in buddhism called sati
which translates roughly to well
mindfulness
the idea behind saathi is to pay
attention to sensory experiences
in order to prevent unproductive
thoughts and emotions from surfacing
having correct sati or mindfulness is
the seventh element of the noble
eightfold path
that ultimately helps one achieve
nirvana transcendental bliss
and complete freedom from suffering the
spiritual goal
of buddhism it's not to be confused with
the hindu practice of sati
where a widow sacrifices herself by
sitting on her dead husband's funeral
pyre
anyway the meditative techniques used to
achieve sati are very similar to the
ones therapists and self-help gurus
teach stressed out millennials and burnt
out executives
minus the ethical and moral principles
that accompany buddhism so how did we
get from this
to this even though buddhism's been
around for a long time
its influence on western medicine is a
little bit more recent
while we might take for granted the idea
that stress is killing us all
it's actually a fairly recent
development in the medical world
before world war ii psychological stress
wasn't really spoken about in the same
way it is today but it did exist
in the 1800s with the rise of industrial
expansion and urbanization
doctors first started reporting cases of
nervousness
in 1869 new york neurologist george m
beer diagnosed a condition called
neurostania where patients suffered from
fatigue
headaches insomnia depression and
anxiety
by the turn of the century neurocenia
was a household term
and people bragged about it like it was
a badge of honor everyone from teddy
roosevelt to jane adams had a diagnosis
the disorder was proof that you are a
productive american
so in some deranged way it made people
look good
those headaches and heart palpitations
just meant you're working too damn hard
of course back then men still couldn't
show weakness so treating their
neurothenia usually involved manly
activities like working on cattle
ranches
or going on wilderness retreats women on
the other hand were told to stay in bed
for weeks at a time
and denied access to any form of
entertainment or even their families and
children
yikes eventually noristhenia fell out of
vogue only to be replaced by something
much more vague stress the modern
concept of stress started in 1936 with
endocrinologist han seli torturing lab
rats on a canadian rooftop
sully would leave them out in the
freezing cold make them starve or
exercise a lot and then dissect them to
see how it affected their insides
he found that all his various tortures
actually caused the same
physical effects their adrenal glands
were different they had stomach ulcers
and they were more susceptible to stroke
and heart attack
even armed with this information sally
struggled to define stress for his
entire career
at one point calling it the non-specific
response to the body to any demand for
change
and later redefined it as the rate of
wear and tear on the body
even though he couldn't explain it he
spent his life promoting the idea
that what was happening to his rats was
happening in people too
he became a high profile sensation
offering 39 books promoting the concept
of stress
and how dangerous it was by the 1950s
stress was a buzzword and scientists and
physicians were trying to figure out its
health risks
that's when celly's work caught the
attention of the tobacco industry
lobbyists began to solicit selly and
other leading stress scientists to start
researching on their behalf
linking things like heart disease to
stress caused from modern life
instead of say cigarettes with a pocket
full of cash
selly argued that tobacco was a great
form of stress relief
and therefore good for you around that
time two american cardiologists meyer
friedman and ray rosenman whose research
was
also bankrolled by the tobacco industry
came up with the idea of the type a
personality
people who were type a subjected
themselves to more stress and pressure
than
other personality types and were
therefore more susceptible to disease
they published a study claiming the risk
of heart disease was twice as high for
men with type a personalities than other
men
this theory has been heavily criticized
for its narrow parameters and
oversimplification of human behavior
but at the time it made a splash in
popular psychology by the 1970s
psychiatrists and psychologists stopped
focusing as much on the harmful side
effects of stress
and instead started trying to figure out
how to make the stress go away
one of them was a phd student at mit
john kabazin who was introduced to
meditation by a zen missionary who came
to speak at his school
kabetzen went on to study meditation and
practice yoga and in 1979
he founded the stress reduction clinic
at the university of massachusetts
medical school
where he implemented an eight-week
program called mindfulness-based stress
reduction
mbsr for short after publishing a few
books and being featured in a pbs
special mbsr started to become very very
popular
it's important to note that part of the
reason mindfulness became so popular
is that it works numerous studies have
shown that mindfulness has
positive effects on emotional and
behavioral stress
and even pain management focusing on
your breathing can lower your heart rate
blood pressure and muscle tension put
simply
practicing mindfulness can calm you down
and make you less anxious
while the science is still iffy these
seem like promising benefits
so what's the problem as i explained
earlier the ancient buddhist tradition
of mindfulness isn't just about
improving concentration
it's about awakening and liberating
people from greed and delusion
but critics say its trendy counterpart
seems to be doing the opposite
mindfulness's greatest benefit might be
for people's
bank accounts a search for mindfulness
on amazon turns up over 40
000 book results alone so it's not
surprising that some critics are calling
the secular practice
mick mindfulness according to the late
psychologist jeremy safran
mick mindfulness is the marketing of
mindfulness practice as a commodity
a brand that promises to deliver mick
mindfulness is the marketing of a
constructed dream
an idealized lifestyle an identity
makeover
no longer a technique linked to its
buddhist origins mindfulness is being
packaged and sold as something you can
buy to cure your burnout
to make you happier and more productive
and it goes way beyond the therapist's
office
silicon valley has become a leader in
this space creating mindfulness apps and
selling them as
brain hacks the company headspace makes
a highly successful subscription based
meditation app
and is valued at 250 million dollars
and there are plenty of others competing
for your downloads calm
aura breathe bootify one's even called
the mindfulness app these apps all
promise to help you find balance in your
life through guided meditations and
breathing exercises
some even boast celebrity voice over
talent for 12.99 a month
matthew mcconaughey will help you fall
asleep how often do we ponder the depth
of the present moment in his book
mcmindfulness
ronald purser says this commodified form
of mindfulness is a
problem because it's too pragmatic in an
effort to make it more compatible with
modern science
and more consumable for the masses
mindfulness has been stripped of all its
buddhist context
and therefore stripped of its ethics
much like a mcdonald's big mac
mindfulness has been scaled and
controlled creating a global branded
product that is easy to sell over and
over again
to anyone purser writes that according
to the earliest recorded teachings of
the buddha
even a person committing premeditated
murder can be exercising mindfulness
it's just wrong mindfulness buddhists
differentiate between right and wrong
mindfulness
samasati and mikasati practicing right
mindfulness means having wholesome
intentions
and positive mental qualities that
consider the well-being of
others as well as oneself so an assassin
focusing on his breathing in order to be
less nervous when it's time to commit a
murder
probably shouldn't be bunched in with
the kind of mindfulness practiced by the
dalai lama
and if this sounds like a stretch
burster notes that even heinrich himmler
took his elite ss
officers on a meditation retreat to a
medieval castle an assassin or nazis
using a meditation app might be an
extreme case
but it shows us that practices to help
keep you calm might not always be in
service of the right thing
and this gets to one of the biggest
criticisms leveled at consumer
mindfulness
it places the task of managing anxiety
on individuals
instead of on society or organizations
as a whole purser says that it makes us
better adjusted cogs which is great for
large corporations
and not so great for everyone else one
of the most common places to find
mindfulness for sale besides the app
store
is in the workplace consultants abound
pushing mindfulness training programs
that can make dysfunctional companies
more compassionate
kinder workplaces but the real sell to
big companies is the claim that
mindfulness programs
will improve work efficiency and reduce
turnover
sign your employees up because happy
workers are more efficient workers and
they won't blame the company
because they're too busy working on
themselves in an article percer along
with zen teacher david loy write
mick mindfulness conveniently shifts the
burden onto the individual employee
stress is framed as a personal problem
and mindfulness is offered as
just the right medicine to help
employees work more efficiently and
calmly
within toxic environments consider a
program developed at google called
search inside yourself
chad ming 10 who developed the program
and is now a tech mindfulness guru
calls it mindfulness mindfulness-based
emotional intelligence training
the program which calls itself
transformative promises to reduce stress
improve focus raise peak performance and
improve personal relationships
you can sign up for it in 50 countries
and more than 150 cities around the
world
according to purser the way mindfulness
is employed in programs like search
inside yourself
seems awfully similar to ones popular in
the 1950s and 60s human relations
and sensitivity training movements these
training programs were largely
discredited
criticized for manipulating counseling
techniques like active listening
employees were made to feel that their
concerns were heard but
bad workplace conditions stayed the same
the tactics they used came to be
referred to as cow psychology
because content and docile cows give
more milk
in other words mindfully focusing on the
present means not
thinking about the past and future or
your terrible boss
and long hours according to historian
russell jacoby
this popular form of forgetting causes
something called
social amnesia when you're in the here
and now you can forget everything else
so while you're being mindful of your
experience your blood pressure might go
down
but you're not thinking about the
reasons why your blood pressure was up
in the first
place the obsessive focus on individual
wellness has become a moral imperative
and i don't just mean taking a lot of
selfies cuddling with your cat and
cutting toxic people out of your life
although that might be your form of
hashtag self-care
habits kabitsin and other mindfulness
gurus argue that this makes everyone
more compassionate
and that if everyone practiced
mindfulness the world would be better
kavitzin's current work discusses
efforts to inject mindfulness into
global politics
helping people be more conscious and
aware of the social and political issues
that plague their neighbors
but the way mindfulness is practiced
these days seems to suggest the opposite
instead of becoming mindfully aware
about the world's issues and how to
solve them
mindfulness conveniently shifts the
burden of making yourself feel better
onto you so that managing stress is your
problem
not the world's it's probably not an
accident that google's program was
called search inside yourself
not search inside your company's
shortcomings sure you can make yourself
feel better by focusing on your
breathing but that won't stop the amazon
from being on fire
it won't make wars go away and it won't
stop your boss from being
mindfulness programs are a great way to
keep workers focused on the therapeutic
benefits of doing a 10 minute body scan
so they will forget to unionize quite
literally mindfulness has people
thinking
at best about themselves and most of the
time about nothing at all
the argument that mindfulness has been
co-opted by large corporations to
placate their workers and turn them into
self-absorbed zombies who buy self-help
books
is pretty convincing but are mindfulness
critics being too harsh
if the main criticism of mindfulness is
that it's politically and socially
flawed
that it breeds inaction and leads to the
acceptance of the status quo
is there a way to practice mindfulness
that could do the opposite
after all we live in a society built on
companies trying to compete for your
attention
24 7. in such a world is mindfulness not
one of the few ways where we can push
away the constant advertising
an institutionalized envy and maintain
some semblance of agency over our own
psyches
and it's for that reason that we can't
really confidently land on whether
mindfulness is deep
or dumb because it works what it works
in service of is the question perhaps
there's a balance a way for stressed out
millennials to center themselves
and get more sleep so they have the
energy to tear down power structures and
make their student loan payments
if people can become mindfully aware of
the world beyond themselves
maybe that would benefit the world at
large and not just big companies
i don't know so what do you think do
benefits of practicing mindfulness
outweigh the negatives do we need to
attach a code of ethics to our
meditation apps
let us know what you think in the
comments thanks to all our patrons who
support the channel and our podcast
don't forget to subscribe and we'll
catch you next time peace
[Music]
you